[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So here,
I have Bhavin and Greg
from the Android team,
who are going to show us
more about what's up with
5G here at Google I/O. So
what's new here, and what
are we showing today?
BHAVIN ROKAD: So, at I/O we want
to demonstrate to developers
how Android is leading the
way when it comes to 5G
and what it means for them.
In 2019, 5G is launching with
over 20 carriers worldwide
and on more than a
dozen Android OEMs.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, cool.
So there are going to be
all these devices out there.
So what APIs have we now added
to Android to allow developers
to use this kind of capability?
GREG LEON: Yeah,
so we've extended
our connectivity manager API
to be 5G aware so that you'll
know when you have an amazing
5G connection from a bandwidth
perspective.
Additionally, we've also added
the metered-ness component
to the API so that you'll know
when that connection's metered
or unmetered.
So you can do interesting
things over the 5G connection.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: All
right, so metered
means you're paying for it
per gigabyte or something
like that.
So that would be a
great opportunity
to download movies
before a flight
or when you're going away
where there's no connectivity.
GREG LEON: That's right.
Yeah, so you can do all of
these great downloads of content
before you jump on a
plane, for example.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
All right, nice.
So from what I understand,
5G is a lot faster
than previous phone networks.
And it sounds like
it has the ability
to do really fast
download so you
have a phone that is 5G aware.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yeah so let's take
a look to help demonstrate 5G
at I/O, we've actually set up
three live networks here at I/O
on a range of six OEM devices.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, wow,
so that's something people
don't get to see every day.
Here at Google Air, we actually
have real cell phone company
base stations for our demos.
So see what this looks like
on a real 5G phone here.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yup.
So one of the challenges
that many of the AAA app
game developers
might run into is
that file sizes get larger
and larger as we make
games more and more immersive.
For instance, this
game is two gigabytes,
and that file size could
mean the difference
between acquiring
the user or not,
especially if they're on the go.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Looks
like it could take hours.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yes, exactly.
So with 5G, we can see that
the download gets kicked off
relatively quickly,
and we're downloading--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: 43 megs.
Oh wow.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: 62.
62 megs.
BHAVIN ROKAD: 120.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Oh, wow, so it's
going like 60 megs at a time.
Wow.
BHAVIN ROKAD: 200, 300, so
we're cranking right along.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah,
that's really quick.
So what technological advances
have they added to 5G in order
to get the speed achievements
that they've never seen?
GREG LEON: Yeah, so we've
done a few things for 5G.
One is new spectrum,
mid band and high band,
increase the
robustness of the link
through beam forming
technology and Massive MIMO.
And also we've
improved latency, which
is really important for gaming
through shorter packet sizes
and distributed
core network, which
is taking the central core
infrastructure of the carrier
and bringing it closer
and closer to the user.
And that's allowed for
much better latency,
and that really matters
to things like gaming.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah, it
sounds like it'd really
help consumers and
also developers
who are going to be
building these kind of apps.
GREG LEON: That's right, yeah.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So--
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yeah, absolutely,
and you can see we're
ready to play the game.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, wow, cool.
That's all done, so
we're ready to roll.
OK.
Thanks for talking to us today.
Appreciate your time and I'm
sure everyone's looking forward
to trying this out.
GREG LEON: Great.
Thank you.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]